alors il ya eu beaucoup de choses sur
sur donc sur ce sur ce drame et cette
première question pourquoi ce fait
divers at-il fait autant la une des
journaux il faut savoir que la veille
françois hollande donc parlé à la
télévision quand même c'était une
élocution qui était très attendu et le
lendemain plus rien regardez cette
histoire à inonder les médias
regardez l'on ne vous a fait une petite
compil externe de télé de la
télé-réalité nobila est en garde à vue
on ne sait pas très bien encore pourquoi
la jeune femme de 22 ans est soupçonné
d'avoir poignardé son compagnon lors
d'une dispute que s'est il passé là été
placé en garde à vue cette nuit et
nabila en garde à vue et on en parle
avec votre invité lawrence piro bonjour
bonjour directrice de la rédaction de
closer nabila est soupçonné d'avoir
blessé à l'aide d'un couteau son
compagnon la nuit dernière dans une
chambre d'hôtel située à boulogne
billancourt
alors on voit là moi je pense aussi à
tous les jeunes pour qui c'est vrai que
nabil a été et est un exemple et ça
c'est pas c'est vraiment ça aussi c'est
ça qui m'a aussi peiné un peu parce que
c'est vrai que voilà ça c'est s'aider
des rives voilà deux de la télé et c'est
une star c'est vrai de la télé voilà
donc on en parle beaucoup et c'est vrai
que c'est ça aussi qui m'a peiné
j'espère que tous les jeunes
voilà ça faire la part des choses et on
se croirait aux états unis presque oui
c'est ça que ça autant déferlé la
chronique comme on dit on dirait une
histoire à l'américaine c'est un alors
on oublie un l'amitié comporta à notre
collègue nabila mais c'est vraiment une
histoire que nous on a l'impression de
mal à qui nous vient tout droit des
states quoi va t il enfin baisser alors
pour noah non la façon dont ces je
trouve que la façon dont cei s'est vendu
aucune pression
la question c'est est-ce que vous
composez que ce soit à l'ipo temps oh
oui on vraiment très fier même dans des
journaux sur terre c'est normal non elle
avait avant de démarrer atp les millions
de fans devraient twitter en français
sur 60 minutes
elle fait partie des stars de ce pays
alors après on aime ou on n'aime pas le
genre la télé rites et paternité mais
personnel ne peut nier que c'est une
superstar aussi bien chez ceux qui la
détestent aussi j'ai donc c'est le rôle
qu'on en parle vous pensez que c'est
normal je crois aussi civiles que les
journaux dits traditionnels ont été
submergées
l influence des réseaux sociaux ça a
tellement déferlé sur les genres sociaux
qui se sont sentis obligés de suivre
parce qu'on aurait pu évidemment parler
de ce fait divers parce que c'est un
fait divers mais en queue de journal
vous le fais parfois dans la
hiérarchisation là ça arrive est d'abord
y avait françois hollande en un
et cette histoire il y avait et après
très vite c'est le passé nabil en
épaulant des mondiaux gilbert basket
vous êtes un journaliste politique ont
plus à la base aussi quand elle aura dix
états unis je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord c'est une histoire française et
pourquoi ça prend cette forte valeur
médiatique parce que nabila est une star
française nabil adorons les fernandel
american graffiti et maintenant la
société fait monter la question c'est
comme si je pense que la question à
faire cette question d'américains vous
assurer que je pense qu'un interne et la
médiatisation c'est fait nous la
médiatisation sur scène mais aussi d un
journal de tf1 de france 2 regarde les
audiences le matin pour savoir à celui
qui a fait plus que l'autre et que
c'était dans les annonces il faut y est
assez normal ça fait de regarder la une
de paris match jo qui va qui va sortir
c'est aussi un axe il a donc de la
télé-réalité heures à la prison
voilà donc il retrace toute la vie de
nabila alors mais c'est vrai que nabila
que j'ai l'impression quand on traite ça
comme ça voilà juste parce que c'est
flou c'est rire mais qu'est ce qui se
passe sur du moment où on avait fait de
halo nommé halo quoi un truc a occupé
l'actualité depuis pendant des semaines
l anc avait rien à mettre derrière
imaginer que la alors qui est un faits
divers et qu'en plus les faits divers
passionne les français
ouais bah oui c'est là où j'ai bien
raison c'est à dire que on a donné en
fait que les français voulaient voir
exact les sacs dans la hiérarchisation
des désinfo c'est assez surprenant mais
c'est quand même des choses quand même
au niveau national c'est normal d'en
parler de la refaire le premier essai
pitre du journal il ya un truc un peu
dérangeant jean michel maire oui c'est
pas c'était au delà de la star s'était
unie que ses aînés qu'on fasse s'était
pressée une icône générationnel serre
que même ceux qui n'aiment pas à nabila
et basse alors ça leur parle parce que
voilà c'est ça la pression qui parle de
nabila au site ou sa réaction ça nous
tente de l'évolution la société de la
façon dont don dans la france avance
dans la télévision chanabé face à ton
coeur et savent donc ça touche tout le
monde ça touche pas que les gens qui
aiment à billère sa touche tous ceux qui
s'intéressent par la façon dont la
france évolue la france un choc quand
des gars comment les médias récupère
cette affaire qui est en cours personne
je fais maintenant
certains journaux je me suis mal exprimé
certaine presse qui je trouve tire des
conclusions hâtives temps à parler de
tout ce conditionnel
oui sonnent ne cessa de la faire
elle-même nourrir nager bien sûr
permettent de parler d'eux cette femme
c'est drôle que ce fameux coup personne
ne sait ce qui s'est passé pour la sauf
que la justice trancherait pas certaines
personnes tirent des conclusions sur ces
rumeurs sauf que leur entourage en parle
bah oui moi je des deux côtés parle
énormément sur les réseaux sociaux dans
les journaux c'est ça la grand-mère de
nabila il ya eu voilà qui accaparent les
femmes besoin de ces graves pour
cautionner ça m'a passionné c'est que
c'est la réalité du paysage aujourd'hui
alors jean-luc où on va ce qu'on est
assez honnête ici il ya beaucoup de gens
aussi qui vous sont tombés dessus à
cause des cafetières voilà ce week-end à
ce que vous voulez dire sur sur sur les
réseaux sociaux
ben parce qu'il ya eu et eu comme un
truc qui dévalait ya vu les cafetières
jeudi voilà comme quoi voilà ça une
importante pour acheter nazi qui a sorti
ça voilà je ne sais pas du tout je n'ai
pas le fameux le seul truc que je peux
dire sur les cas tiers c'est que il ya
quelques semaines
nabil avait mal pris le fait que
jean-michel elle a cofondé ghzaya mais
en plus en toute naïveté mais qui
n'avait pas fait que tu vas faire un mot
et la fois suivante elle était de retour
dans les 4 hier jeudi ça te dérange et
dans les cas tierces que je me suis dit
nous on a l'habitude l autodérision
cheyrou je dis est ce que ça te fait
anormalement mais j'adore les quatre
tiers mais je vais la cité deux grands
lamas 10 et trop stylées d'être dedans
trop stylé et avec ma famille on adore
ça donc voilà j'ai été assez surpris par
ce magazine
je n'aime pas le commenter parce que
personne ne sait vraiment comment sais
tu n'es c'est une énorme bêtise alors il
ya aussi des gens qui se sont amusés à
2,2 de 7,2 de ce drame aussi alors je
vous lis même mois voilà j'ai sorti de
trois balles à la radio avec avec
benhaim et lycées des éditorialistes
après moi par exemple quand canteloup
fait des vannes là dessus honnêtement ça
me je passe il est donc ans de métier
ayant relancé l'extraction à gerra ou
sexy landry et mais c'est leur métier
après il y en a certains qui étaient
survoltés
moi j'ai trouvé qu'avec du capital y en
avait certains qu'ils soient les envies
ans l'âge est un moyen de me faire des
retweets et ça a bien sûr tous les mois
des gens qui sont pas très connus qui
sont dit je vais savourer ces 2e la
popularité de nabila voilà en gros les
deux oublis encore une fois pas drôle du
mois je fasse super d'accord égouts à
partir du moment quand on à twitter on
peut pas demander aux jours d'avoir le
recul nécessaire d'une bonne blague web
twitter et on est bien contents et nous
pendant les tubes à regarder les
panneaux soient pas des gens mais je
vais vous dire et je vais redire l'élite
les meilleurs vins les meilleurs vannes
sont venues des téléspectateurs moi j'ai
laissé ça je vous le dis les meilleurs
vins après ya deux trois animateurs dans
la dgi en tête qui ont essayé de se
faire mousser voilà en sortant de trois
black était là je suis d'accord c'est
que quand on est orné notoriété on
réfléchit à ce sera exactement de faire
une vanne sur celle là je suis d'accord
je pourrais vous parler de tout après la
pareille à dany boon qui inquiète c'est
sympa 4,8 m qui truquent lui qui s'est
fait vraiment tombé dessus
je trouvais que c'était aussi exagéré de
tomber sur dani comme ça voilà que voilà
si je trouvais pas si je trouve que
laval était plutôt voilà en gros la
voile à dany je trouve qu'on me tomber
dessus ça va je trouvais pas que ça
vraiment il ya eu il ya eu bien pire
comme par d'autres gens qui sont moins
connus que dany en plus d'animer on peut
pas dire qu'il ait envie de surfer sur
la popularité de nabil abu leila juste
fait ça je trouvais que c'était c'était
voilà ça j'ai trouvé ça plutôt plein
mais c'est parce que je vous ai dit tout
à l'heure c'est que simplement 2 2 quand
il ya un drame comme ça qui se passe
souvent il ya deux voies enfin il ya un
temps de latence avant que les gens
fassent des vannes et là c'est arrivé
tout de suite et là tu te rends compte
que les gens considèrent pas nabila est
thomas comme des êtres humains ont fait
rigoler avec ça alors regardez on a on à
nicolas canteloup donc regarder ce qu'il
a fait et les guignols les policiers
reçoivent un appel t30 à l'os et nabila
les policiers croisent tout de suite à
une blague
ra tranche nabila pourtant rappelle
alone on met à l'eau la suite vous la
connaissez la police n'arrête nabila et
découvre que contrairement à elle son
casier judiciaire
eh bien c'était christophe hondelatte
pour faisais moi entrer au moins une
fois s'il vous plaît dans ce lac est
coupable
de là à faire de ta priorité un vulgaire
fait divers qui arrive à une bimbo de
télé réalité ça discute
tu préfères quoi toi honnêtement si on
compare ces deux informations
la mia ou fillon je n'ai pas vu ça comme
ça mais c'est vrai que je peux vous
faire agir là-dessus fois par exemple
j'ai trouvé très drôle tout canteloup
j'ai trouvé moins drôle les guignols ne
savent pas de rôle à la funai mouchès
parce qu'il n'y a plus de limites
mauvais pour fait il ya plus de risques
quand c'est drôle tout passe là qu'on
touche à danser très drôle ou pas c'est
subjectif cyril avril ou pas c'est
subjectif
si vous aimez mabilat ou son entourage
ou thomas son entourage vous voyez ça ça
l'est pas donc en sac ses clefs de plus
entre des vignerons mais je ne lis pas
nous la connaissons pas finir énorme je
ne dis pas ça je dis simplement que
cette affaire-là affranchis totalement
le monde médiatique et des réseaux
sociaux de toute limite permise de tous
qu'il n'y en a plus maintenant
guy jaune et ses débuts sur toute la
dent dans l'histoire des guignols il
réduisait nabila physique alors c'est
quoi une personne quoi qu'il arrive
personne fiable à sa propre personne est
évident
allo